I go down One Direction you miss out on
another thing can I give you some really
really good news no matter what you ever
decide you'll never know if the other
thing would have been anything sitting
around and debating which options better
will never show you which option was
better I passed on investing in Uber
from one of my best friends twice had I
made a normal 25 000 investment like I
was doing at the time I would have made
somewhere close to
I did trade attention and build
businesses
just doing it's not enough you got to do
it right meaning I wouldn't do it if I
was going to mail it in because I'm
going to leave a bad impression and
that's a waste of you know energy on
both sides and so you know this is just
a clip to wrap up the day the reality is
I'm [__] exhausted at this point
I think there's a form and I think it's
this I mean both of those were bangers I
can easily do that at bed at midnight
like the next day I think it just makes
it very compelling content and maybe we
can do a visual where it looks like
audio and like give it a brand like
Gary's recap or a deeper Insight let's
go even triple that up hey everyone when
you're watching it is how we do it
you're watching the [__] pasta being
made right now if you've noticed I'm
starting to talk about being good at the
craft more packed I think I'm gonna go
even deeper into detail well do you
think about the first three seconds and
the thumbnail like I'm trying to go a
little further it's like okay it's
established you gotta make a [__] load
of content now I think I can get one
more and so everyone will be launching
right now that's what this is
like you just watch
when Sydney now in the morning pretty
excited feel really fresh not that much
sleep but kind of like speaks to being
overall rested cut down on travel post
covid on things that I need to do and I
think it's adding up like there's been
many flights this year that I did not
take that I could have in the past I
feel like I've banked that rest so for
times like this when I have to go hard
and that you know sometimes you get
balance and extremities it's not like
balancing every day it's okay with being
lazy for a month that it's okay with
going super hard for a month you've got
to time it that's life they [__]
dominate the day
[Music]
when I come into markets for everybody
who's watching the Vlog I like to get
together with senior marketers and shoot
the [__] just Jam so we've been talking
about like the changing landscape for a
lot of you that are watching you believe
in social media marketing but you'd be
surprised how many people still think a
television ad is a better way to sell
[__] you couldn't believe how fun it is
to sit in these rooms and talk about
Innovation AI influencer marketing
YouTube thumbnails reels creative
strategies plus I love hearing
perspectives of people that see it
differently than me and really going
back and forth and like it's almost like
battle rap meets a jam session meets
like a Dead Poet Society like I get to
meet people I get to know people better
some of my favorite stuff to do and as
you can see throughout this week's Vlogs
I'm just doing a lot of it a lot of
sessions a lot of jamming getting to
know people and I'm enjoying it
this is fun you know team I think
there's a lot of things running through
my mind first of all it's really good to
see you I want to be the best in the
world at sock kasak is the answer to
where this is all going to go you have
so much permission here to win we've got
to push ourselves biggest challenges
that we face is getting that quantity
going through without the strenuous
approvals process on there and I'm
hoping that's going to ease up a little
bit more Let me let me jump in real
quick you know when I talk about like
use me do you understand that if I just
stay up till like nine o'clock one day
get on Zoom and speak with the client I
can change that they may decide to take
a swing at it they may not when I'm like
email me everyone's like but I don't
want to upset my boss it's just not how
it works here because it's not bad it's
making it good the more I can make them
realize that's how much I'm going to be
involved the more they'll do it
themselves I'd rather you guys and gals
go out and make it and it get never
approved just for you to get the Reps of
making good CC's but you're making it
because you think it's going to get
approved that's not interesting to me
make that and the [__] that you think is
fire
let them say no I need you to get these
kind of reps because it's all going to
get approved eventually you understand
thank you
I appreciate all of you being here it's
like super fun to travel around the
world and see what people are up to make
connections make relationships I know
you talk a lot about like regret and
mindset and stuff like is it perfectly
all right like I'm
is it okay just being okay if you're
happy with okay what do you think it's I
think it's the ultimate peace and in a
society where they're constantly pushing
like make more money earn more money
status I don't if you're personally
happy you think that's all it's I mean
of course I'm a businessman and I love
business but I think it's crazy to chase
money you know as a singular kpi I'm so
at peace at all times and I'm desperate
to find ways to communicate if you're
achieving what you're talking about
You've Won like to me waking up with
anxiety is like devastating I know you
know it's okay right I gotta go okay
pleasure thank you I'll see you out
there
[Music]
guys
Sydney what's good
thank you thank you so happy to be here
I think people burn out because they're
not doing their thing a lot of people
fail because they talk about [__] they
think money will be in but you don't
need to be an expert you're the expert
of your life experiences you can talk
about anything
I'd highly recommend talking about stuff
that you're interested in because it
becomes sustainable if you ask me to
hang a picture right now on a wall I'd
be burned out by the time I got to the
Hammer
that's not my thing I don't want to do
that [__] right like I'm exhausted I can
work 19 hours a day I can literally do
this in front of this audience for the
next 48 hours straight and not sleep you
asked me to go walk a dog I'll be
sleeping within the first second
yeah you guys ready
uh you spoke about loving your life
loving it loving your life yes and you
um spoke about a whole lot of people
that don't love their life yes when did
you start loving your life I started
loving my life fully the day I was done
with school so I would say yeah I'm
being serious like school was a burden
on me and I hated it and it took up a
lot of time my bigger question to you is
what's making you not love your life
it's a great question so answer it
not achieving not achieving what I think
that I can achieve for whom for me why
are you doing that to yourself yourself
I think that I'm capable of more than
one thing so it's a matter of do I go in
this direction do I go in that direction
but what are you scared of that's not
letting you make decisions missing out
on what on the other things that if I go
down One Direction you miss out on
another thing can I give you some really
really good news no matter what you ever
decide you'll never know if the other
thing would have been anything sitting
around and debating which options better
will never show you which option was
better I passed on investing in Uber
from one of my best friends twice had I
made a normal 25 000 investment like I
was doing at the time I would have made
somewhere close to 500 million dollars
the reason it doesn't even sit with me
is I also know had I've done that my
life would have been completely
different I believe that you're scared
to like lose that's why you're not doing
anything and that it feels better to
make pretend you're capable instead of
seeing if you're capable you're
protecting yourself you got to practice
losing my man
instead of making pretend you won't lose
thank you you're welcome
ladies and gentlemen
thank you Sydney thank you so much
get home safe
that was some great stuff huh
[Music]
foreign
yo brother
of course my brother thank you I hope
you enjoyed I consumed your content and
I feel just grateful I came from Costa
Rica and I really appreciate it bro I
love you brother good luck to you you're
welcome
[Music]
welcome as he makes his way to the stage
it's Gary V
foreign
how would you break a brand new artist
if they're under your agency my only
signing artist to prove they know how to
Market most of these artists are equally
creators the a r business has changed
quite a bit you don't need to go to the
bars at two in the morning and find them
you just go to the social platforms and
see it it's very clear which artists
understand how to be creatives I
wouldn't take the risk of signing an
artist just on the quality of the music
there's too many people with Quality
Music and some of them also know how to
create creative for the platforms that
have the end consumers attention and
then once you have that the artist is
doing the work you can build
infrastructure around them but they're
native to the understanding of how to
create Wellness X is a growth hacker he
was going at that for a while Lil Nas X
is more Mr Beast than he is Kanye West
and that is a blueprint to where this is
going yeah I think I speak for everyone
the billion dollars in this room where
I'm going to say a huge thank you so
everyone
thank you
where's the camera
you ready
I'm just [__] exhausted that's how
I'm ending it see you
[Music]